emmanuel macron the rematch the pair
first faced off in 2017 when macron took
the presidency
voters are taking to the polls again to
decide between them but what's different
this time
[Music]
first let's look at marine le pen it's
the third time the far-right candidate
has run previously she's hammered home
anti-immigration anti-muslim and anti-eu
sentiment but this time around she's had
a pr revamp and presented herself as
much softer in an attempt to detoxify
her image
she has backtracked on some of his more
controversial stances and embraced
republicanism she's also expelled
militants holding excessively radical
views um which included her own father
and founder of the party
jean-marie le pen
and finally in 2018 she changed the
party's name from juana nationale to a
rasamo national or national rally as
it's known in english
she's been helped along the way by an
even further right candidate eric zamore
who has spouted controversial
replacement conspiracies
in comparison to zamor who has said
white europeans are being replaced by
non-europeans le pen comes across as
moderate
in terms of her policies this time she's
on the right on cultural issues and on
the left on economic ones and with her
radical plan to scrap income tax for
those under 30 she's really appealed to
the young
the cost of living crisis is at the core
of her campaign in this election as she
tries to align herself with the poor and
working class le pen has been
campaigning to cut v80 on fuel gas and
electricity from 20
to 5.5 percent appealing to those
struggling with rising energy costs
as president emmanuel macron is not the
same man we saw go up against marine le
pen in 2017. he's no longer the
fresh-faced upstart he was he stayed
france through a global pandemic faced
off with putin and secured an impressive
low unemployment rate and high growth
um so macron is
seen as having the qualities to be a
statesman um and to really defend and
protect the image of france in the world
the problem is that he also does not
come across as someone who is close to
the people so he's frequently viewed as
someone who's quite detached
and who does not understand
um
let's say the man on the streets
problems so he has still this kind of
the spore of the president of the rich
which potentially makes it a little bit
tricky for him to speak to certain
sections of the electorate that he
probably does need to actually win the
election the macron of 2022 is also
economically and socially more towards
the right his flagship policy of raising
the retirement age has also made him
very unpopular
the first round of voting is mainly to
decide which two candidates will face
each other in the second it is possible
for a candidate to win in the first
round but they'll need over 50 per cent
of the vote this has only happened once
when napoleon won 74 percent of the
votes this year macron 27.8
and le pen got 23.2 percent not far
behind was the far left candidate
melisha who got 22 percent of the vote
though he didn't make the final race his
share of the vote is very significant
and here's why
going from 12 candidates to just two
means that all those other votes are up
for grabs far-right candidate eric zumer
seven percent are most likely to go to
le pen
but less certain are where melashon's
voters will go representing over
one-fifth of voters they're key to who
will win and they could go one of three
ways
some of them are going to go to macron
because they dislike marine le pen's
social conservatism her very hard-line
stance on immigration and nationalism
her non-progressive and non-inclusive
attitudes towards things like lgbt
rights
but there's another group who are going
to be persuaded by
le pen because she is actually quite
similar to miloshawn in her
attitudes towards france's position on
the global stage she's not keen on the
eu she's hostile to nato
she wants to introduce more
governments by referenda on all of those
fronts she's actually quite similar to
miloshong and like him she has tried to
position herself as a voice of the
neglected working class so there is a
core electorate there for milo that will
swing to her and then there's a third
group who are probably not going to vote
for either candidate and for a lot of
them extension is an appealing choice
because they don't like either candidate
[Music]
key to securing votes and the issue top
of the list in voters minds is the cost
of living crisis the so-called president
of the rich may initially be on the back
foot here but he could yet unveil new
policies in this area le pen on the
other hand has been focusing on this
during her campaign promising cheaper
petrol and essential goods and banning
immigrants from welfare
meanwhile macron has been preoccupied
with the war in ukraine
when it first broke out it was a big
boost for macron because he was seen as
being very presidential while the other
candidates struggled to get a look in
because this dominated the headlines but
as the campaign has progressed it's come
to hurt him because he's had to focus
too much on that at the expense of the
rest of the election campaign and voters
are now feeling ignored and that he's
not taking the election seriously enough
le pen herself has had close ties with
putin not only a long-standing supporter
she even took a loan from him which she
is still paying back
that track record remains and i think
macron is going to try harder now to
pull her down on it the big question is
can the far right really win the french
presidency
[Music]
you